we are in overtime Vigo is there any
historical figure in American policy
politics who you could see yourself
portraying in a film anybody you admire
no really
you know no I you know in my urge or
joshing ttan know why cuz he was a
slaveholder yeah Vicki say you don't go
with the argument that it was just the
way things were done back yeah that's
not a good enough reason no Jelani is it
fair to compare the tactics of black
lives so I'm guessing it Romney is
completely out it's in fair to compare
the tactics of black lives matter to
Occupy Wall Street who's doing that yeah
I don't know that this is the case I
mean aside from them both being protest
movements on the Left I don't know that
you say that there's a whole lot of
basis for comparison another thing I
think is that black lives matter has a
organizational structure that's kind of
become increasingly defined as time has
gone on and that didn't really happen so
much when occupy okay Frank do you think
Hillary Oh more no more no no you killed
me already
Frank you you came out very feisty I
died yeah I know I died no you did that
was a very entertaining television was
that none
honestly I mean you just came out loaded
for bear I don't know why I mean I've
been known you for a long time you've
been on this show used to consult on
this show you just you know that's fine
but you you you you you kicked my ass
place I have a gift for you I didn't
kick your ass but you did have feisty
with your throw to them what does that
say I already hate alright so Frank do
you think Hillary's campaign slogans on
with her and better together are working
for her I mean you're the master of
changing people's minds with words you
go to your evil laboratory and come on
hey I mean Frank came up with the death
tax instead of the estate tax and
everybody changed on that I I don't
think she has a good team doing this
right she did those are not good right
Frank and I would tell her the National
Convention no teleprompter she's been
doing this now for 25 years chic she can
do it really she comes out no
teleprompter 2530 minutes just looking
straight at the American people just
anything just Trump's it just like like
starts going off on how great she is she
speaks in complete sentences that's not
bad
[ __ ] do you think living abroad has
given you a different perspective on
American politics maybe I think just
watching how people watch the for
example presidential campaign it's
different than the way it happens here
because there it matters they really
think about who's gonna be President
because we have so much power militarily
awesome and economical you get I mean it
must be much more informed than our
horrible you can get you can inform
yourself here you can you have to work
hard yeah you have to but yeah you have
to everywhere I mean there's there's
there's right wing left wing press
everywhere and you have to make up your
mind it says people are lazy I mean when
I Drive I drive across the country a lot
United States and I listen to the radio
and it's very difficult to hear anything
other than a kind of scripted right-wing
diatribe all the time unless you get
close to a major city and then you can
listen to some you know alternative
media that's more Center or a liberal
the upgrade from the car you read take
but I do it to one with FM FM is really
coming around
no I'm serious I mean you can't yes true
in FM I realize that a couple months ago
but you know I get up every morning and
I and I make myself listen no matter
where I'm in the world through you know
we use my computer I'll listen to to to
Fox I'll listen to Sean Hannity savage
all all those guys I can take about 10
minutes resting minutes they're better
man than I know but I want I want to
hear I wonder what's going on it's
better to know know what people are
saying sure okay but it takes work se
we'll all the GOP elite boycotting the
convention next week have any effect on
Trump's candidacy no both bushes are not
going the last two nominees are not
going Romney and McCain the governor of
the state where the convention is being
held is not gone Wow will this have any
effect on Trump's candidacy
yeah probably elect them nothing that
Antonio sabato jr. canceled we're good
here alright thank you very much thank
you folks you're a terrific audience
you